make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin what's going on guys this is
rob and for a long time you guys have
been asking me to cover the mask
uh and i'm gonna go ahead and cover it
right or technically it's issue number
zero
right just this kind of like the
original stanley ipkis story so if you
remember the mask with jim carrey it's
basically that story
it's a lot darker and it's it's kind of
nuts i don't imagine the video will do
super well but honestly i don't care i
think sometimes you just got to do
videos for the sake of doing it because
it's just fun
but having said that this video's got
some crazy moments right like this story
has some absolutely insane moments and
it's
nothing like the movie i mean it is but
it's much much darker than the movie
right so
stanley ipkiss is originally given to us
and the way this kind of kind of opens
up stanley ipkis is given to us
as this guy who's kind of on rough terms
with this girl and the reality is that
he just hasn't really been paying enough
attention to her
recently that kind of a thing and he's
also kind of presented to us as being
pretty meek right not in the sense that
he's like a coward but in the sense that
he harbors a lot of dark feelings and so
on right now this comes by way of the
fact that as he's leaving with the mask
that he's buying for her not really
realizing what it is that he's kind of
set upon by a handful of bikers they
basically end up scratching his car he
cusses them out and they come back and
start beating him up because he cuts
them out in the first place so it's one
of these things where it kind of
establishes
there's not a lot not a whole lot going
on with this guy now one of the things
that happens is that these darker
thoughts he has
comes after dealing with the bikers and
he's imagining himself like shooting
them
beating them to death setting him on
fire so obviously he's got some pretty
dark intentions here and that's one of
the things to understand
is that a lot of time a lot of instances
uh we all have these kind of thoughts
right the difference between
a person who's like a psychopath and a
person who's not is that a person who is
a psychopath lacks remorse in its
entirety writing cares nothing about how
their actions affect
other people technically there's
clinical diagnoses for becoming a
psychopath it's not any one thing
you have to satisfy something like six
out of ten criteria the same thing for
like a narcissistic personality disorder
or anti-social personality disorder you
have to satisfy a certain number of
criteria in order to accurately receive
that diagnosis but for
for this guy right here he doesn't
really express a lot of remorse in what
he's in these thoughts that he has
and it's just kind of angry all the time
now in that moment as soon as he goes
and really kind of knocks on her
apartment door
he's met by kind of the disembodied
voice of the mask and he's kind of like
this is
you know kind of kind of weird right
doesn't quite know how to react to it
but before he can really give it a whole
lot of thought catherine answers and
we're kind of given the state of their
relationship again that is kind of on
the rocks it's a little rough
uh they're not really breaking up but it
really kind of feels like it's on its
way there and he basically presents her
with a gift right now it's a mask that
she's wanted for quite some time
and she adds it to her collection and
where she is a little frustrated at the
idea that he feels like you can kind of
smooth things over with like gifts
as opposed to like sitting down talking
and kind of explaining where it is that
he's coming from at the end of the day
everything seems to kind of work you
know and it's kind of like okay you know
like you know
we've basically kind of fixed this
little bit of a rift but everything
basically goes belly up when he wakes up
in the middle of the night and he goes
to the bathroom only to find the mask of
sitting on the toilet and initially he
thought that like catherine had put it
there in order to scare him and so he's
like well let's put it on let's see if
she likes the same feeling as soon as he
puts the mask on the story goes downhill
from here there's it's it's just a
descent into total madness
this this first like three minutes that
we've been recording here
is the is really it's the last vestige
of sanity in the story
it goes crazy right so the first thing
he does with this mask suit
because it kind of takes on and it sort
of brings out all these dark inhibitions
these dark desires
brings him to the forefront and just
kind of let him lets him remove all his
inhibitions entirely then he immediately
starts going out there and tracking down
the bikers uh and immediately just
starts causing problems for them right
like starting crap with these bikers and
shows up there and it's just kind of
like uh so like you guys are making too
much noise and it's like what you know
and and one of the guys calls him like a
fruit right because he looks like a gay
guy
keep in mind this is written back in the
90s so at that point in time it was
socially acceptable to hate on gay
people
not anymore we're a little more
enlightened in that way thank god but
the whole the the important thing here
is that he immediately like pulls off
his face right to reveal like the mask
faces there right so right off the bat
we're talking about shape shifting
abilities
and then just starts tormenting these
guys right like poking him in the eyes
beating the crap out of him like you
know crushing him with a wrench he sets
one of the guys on fire
he grabs like a an uzi that he seems to
kind of manufacture out of thin air and
when one of the guys goes to shoot him
with a shotgun he just grabs it and just
starts spraying the guy down right and
then sets the whole place on fire
and leaves it's it's nuts right i mean
he just like tears these guys apart in
the movie it was nothing like this one i
don't think there were any bikers no
there were it was in an alleyway and
like he had the the whole uh
what is it the balloons and he's like a
tommy gun you know like
but the the movie was a lot more
light-hearted and certainly to a degree
more family friendly than this is right
like this is this is
nuts but right off the bat the things
that are kind of established here
is that one he's making a list right
he's got a kill list and he's kind of
going through and figuring out who it is
he's gonna take out on this list
number two uh the mask is almost an
addiction for him
right because all he does is like watch
the news he sits in front of the tv all
day watches the news all these terrible
stories and things that are going on
he dresses in like this this kind of
army fatigues he's obsessed with guns
right off the bat he's just becoming
you know exceedingly extreme this really
comes to a head when an argument breaks
out between him and catherine and he
goes to hit her and so he kind of starts
putting off all these different
personality traits these character
traits where he's becoming a lot more
violent and a lot more sadistic
and so from there like he basically ends
up leaving he snatches up the mask and
takes off
then he goes to yorkie's mufflers right
now yorkie's mufflers is giving us right
off the bat it's kind of like this
depiction of what we expect when it
comes to like a mechanic shop
doing the best they can to rip you off
and so what we find out is these guys
are pretty shady right they've done
things like cut people's brake lines
they've
basically finding ways to screw people
out of money in order to get them to pay
more
by creating problems that didn't exist
and say well now you gotta you gotta get
this problem fixed
and so they kind of start joking about
stanley ipkis about how they basically
screwed him over with a muffler
and and caused them problems cheated him
out of money well then here comes the
mask right here comes stanley with the
mask
getting ready to help them understand
their place in the bigger picture now
we'll find
out what happens to those guys later on
down the line but then we end up going
and visiting what is in effect
a woman named miss gazo or mrs gaza
right who was basically his teacher and
mrs gazzo was presented to us as this
woman who was
kind of a dick right she was she was
kind of rude or i wouldn't necessarily
say cruel but one of these things where
like she has a kid come up to spell
tuberculosis and when he doesn't really
spell it and the kids start laughing at
him when he starts getting it wrong
she doesn't really do anything to
correct the kids right she lets this kid
deal with getting laughed at now
honestly this can kind of go one of two
ways one of the things to understand is
that back in the 1990s you did kind of
have an anti-bullying movement but at
the same time bullying itself was
thought to in a lot of ways be a
necessity right because it taught you
resilience it taught you the fact that
there are people in the world who just
aren't going to like you
for any number of reasons your skin
color the way your hair looks the
clothes you wear or whatever
arbitrary standard they decide and going
forward in the world and understanding
that and then dealing with bullies in
the sense of like getting into fights
standing up for yourself was a way to to
kind of build confidence right to accept
the fact that people aren't going to
like you but it doesn't mean you have to
accept it right it doesn't mean you have
to like let them give you a hard time
that fighting them and standing up for
yourself sure might result in you
getting beat up
but at the same time it shows people and
it really kind of teaches you as a
person you're not just going to let
people give you a hard time and make fun
of you uh because you've got a measure
of self-respect
in recent years that's kind of changed a
lot and whether or not that's a good
thing it really depends on who you talk
to
but back then that's just kind of how
things were done right in school and so
it's one of these things where you kind
of have like ipkis who shows up here
and because of the fact that he really
experienced a lot of this treatment at
the hands of mrs gazzo or at least it
was allowed to happen he in turn
torments her right and like just kind of
like grabs her like drops around her
back right it seems to kind of break her
back and she tells this little kid she's
like you know please help me and i think
i
think i've broken something and if kiss
is like no like that's that's not gonna
happen right and kind of just like takes
it to this chick
and then seemingly kills her right and
so it's just like geez like he literally
has this list of people
that he's going after now as far as
yorkie's mufflers go essentially because
of what's happened here the cops are hot
on the trail of stanley ipkis now they
don't really know what's going on
they don't really have like a full
indication of what's happening here all
they really know is that somebody's
going around and committing various
crimes for these guys here he took one
of the guys put him on an engine hoist
and then just started stuffing like
tools in his head right so the guy looks
like pinhead with like
wrenches sticking out of his head the
other guy he grabbed the muffler and
rammed it down his throat right so it's
just like
geez right i mean he just he took it to
these guys and so you've got a cop by
the name of callaway who's kind of
following this whole thing
going through and and he's really kind
of the main detective here you've also
got another kid and kind of picking up
with with ipkis again you know he's
walking down the street he sees this kid
getting bullied you know and
and he's like you know these kids are
like you know give me your lunch money
you know that that kind of a thing and
it's kind of nuts because you know he he
asked him he's like you know like what's
what's going on here and this kid who
was getting bullied he's like what's
wrong with your head man
and he's like nothing's wrong with my
head and just like cracks this kid who's
getting bullied over the head leaves him
there and it just lets him get bullied
by the rest of the kids so it's a pretty
dark perception
and pretty twisted the way that it's
being done right and so what he ends up
doing
is heading back home and then basically
just crashing out at catherine's house
she immediately takes the mask and then
throws it away right she's like this
mask whatever it is has changed the
personality of stanley and it has right
because
what this mask has done is because of
what he's capable of right he can
survive being shot
you know he really is in a lot of ways
immortal right and that kind of
immortality is a real world
depiction of like being on the internet
right for example like when you're on
the internet you go on reddit twitter
facebook different things like that you
can be anybody that you want to be
especially if you're talking about a
website like reddit where there is no
real name requirement for using that
website and so people can just
be their worst selves right the
internet's an answer to the question if
you put people in a circumstance where
there are no consequences for the things
they do
what kind of people will they be and the
answer is they'll be terrible people
consequences is the only thing that
keeps up from keeps us from being our
worst
selves and when you take consequences
away people will show you who they
really are right so the
the internet is the best depiction of
what humanity is really about right what
we as human beings
are really really like uh it's kind of
like the grocery card litmus test right
for those of you guys who don't know
what that is it's really cool thing bear
with me here for a second
the grocery cart litmus test is this
test that determines uh whether
people are good or bad right and it's
this idea that putting the grocery cart
back
is one of these situations where there's
no benefit for doing the right thing and
no consequence for doing the wrong thing
and so what happens if you're in a
situation where there is no consequence
for doing the wrong thing but there's no
benefit for doing the right thing people
will inherently
do the wrong thing and it's it's you
know it's kind of cynical
but it's also very truthful in terms of
how how it allows you to see humanity
but at the same time like when ipkis
wakes up and realizes the mask has been
thrown away he immediately starts to
freak
and that's really where a lot of this
comes from insofar as this kind of
addiction here right because the mask
allowed him to do pretty much anything
he wanted to he could get just this
you know get this revenge on the people
that he felt had wronged them and do it
with impunity you know there was no way
they could do anything to him they
couldn't stop him they couldn't hurt him
right he was able to just kind of
operate without any real fear of
consequence
and that's addicting because what it did
is it basically allowed him to become
god and the question got asked is would
you give that up
and the answer is no most people would
not why you give them the power of god
they would do all kinds of crazy things
with it but the last thing they would do
is give it up willingly and so it's one
of these things where it's a very much
very much an addicting feeling to him
right not only that you know where
catherine kind of brings up this idea
that god has caused these huge
changes in your personality that is very
true and he starts to realize that yeah
this really has
kind of changed me in a negative way and
then goes as far as to kind of use to
himself i mean you know i guess i don't
really need the mask i pretty much got
everybody on my list anyway so it
doesn't really matter but then from
there he kind of starts to muse to
himself about what happened with with
the guys at yorkie's muffler when he's
watching the news and catherine
overhears him being
being excited by the fact that these
guys were murdered in brutal fashion
and for her that's the last thing she's
like get out right get like grab
yourself
leave like i don't want you here anymore
you're a guy who's amusing and enjoying
the fact that people have been
killed right like i cannot abide this
anymore and so ultimately what ends up
happening
is the mask basically returns to the
apartment of catherine sitting on her
nightstand and ipkis comes back trying
to find it digging through the trash
now ultimately he ends up breaking in
her home in order to locate it and
because she hears a break-in he
basically you know she basically ends up
calling the cops now the cops do end
arriving or end up arriving on the scene
but only after she knocks him out using
a vase and so when the once that happens
like you basically have like these cops
showing up and and stanley ipkis manages
to get a hold of the mask
dons it and goes back to his just kind
of crazy self and where catherine kind
of tries to talk them try to you know
try to tell the cop hey look you know
i'm sorry i called you here for no
reason i thought there was some kind of
a break-in and basically lies
right and saying that like you know her
boyfriend was on a business trip and
then he came back early and it surprised
her and that kind of a thing that the
cops hear
you know ip kiss or hear the mask
talking and it's a very inhuman voice
and so they're like no we need to check
this out right so they kind of go
through the whole place you know looking
through everything
as soon as they get through there he
immediately slaughters them right like
those those two cops you just brutally
kills them and initially
it's this kind of thing where
catherine's like i mean what what like
she has no real idea on how to process
any of this right like she can't really
handle what she's seeing another cop
comes in and then he basically grabs the
guns and kills that one cop shoots him
to death and then more cops start
showing up something like a dozen cops
start showing up
at that point he kind of goes down the
stairs shape-shifting into an old woman
and it's like hey like they're that way
everybody you know they're that way and
as soon as the cops are passed he
basically dons a bazooka
and blows them to pieces right and
people are just like what in the heck is
going on here right following that
even more cops show up right so it's
like lambs to the slaughter now one of
the guys who was
who was in there and wasn't killed by
ipkis kind of tells uh tells you know
catherine hey look like you know
it's crazy out there but i'll go in and
get it sorted out besides you know if i
survive the ordeal i'll probably get a
piece of tail you know for being so
brave you know that kind of a thing and
so as soon as he steps out you've got
stanley ipkits you know the mask who's
pretending to be a cop
who points a finger at the guy who just
came out and said like that's him man he
wasn't here before and so like the cops
immediately opened fire
right and then once they realized that
like it kisses the guy who you know this
the ipkis is still alive and he's among
their ranks
he kills all of them right so literally
just brutally murdering
everyone he sees just literally just
picking them off right he goes to the
roof there's cops on the roof who are
looking for him and he just starts
taking out all these cops beating him to
death different things like that just
like bludgeoning these guys and so
finally he turns around
and there's like two dozen cops that
have been called in by callaway with
callaway their
callaway there with him and it's just
like all right guys fire it well right
and like they just
unload on it right i mean just spray him
down with bullets but he's like a
cartoon character right he goes falling
off the building and then brings himself
to a screeching halt when he goes to
land in this cop car
uh that has a guy named jerry in the
back who committed a crime and so he's
just kind of like okay
like let's go do this right and
literally at this point there's not
really any rhyme or reason to why he's
doing what he's doing
he's just doing this because he can
right at this point like he's kind of
satisfied all the
the the list that he had he's just
killing people arbitrarily right just
doing it willy nilly because there
really isn't any consequence he's just
kind of going through and doing what
have you
and so literally like he ends up go you
know crashing into the store right
you've got the two people right this
woman who's buying from the or this this
old man who's buying from the cashier
and you know i was like thank you for
shopping and smiling he's like wow right
this car just comes
smashing in through the window you know
and he's just like he goes riding
through snatching up a few things you
know and then like throwing groceries or
throwing money at the the grocer and you
know he's like he's like take my money
woman he's like this is the worst
service i've ever had my entire life
i'll never shop here again
it's very joker-esque in terms of how
you see this right which is actually why
you get a really cool story where the
mask and the joker meet
um but it's really really interesting
here right because as he kind of goes
through again it's just
a pure unadulterated mayhem and conflict
that's all that it is there's just no
real rhyme or reason he ends up chasing
after some guy named corey mcwhorter who
owes him like 60 bucks
right chases this guy down and then
you've got the cop cars who were just
like okay let's just do what we have to
do
and they basically ram him off the side
and into a building and so at that point
it's kind of like okay like let's go
find this guy right let's let's let's go
see what's going on with him you know
he's probably smeared all over the
concrete or smashed into the building
because he wasn't wearing a seatbelt
only for the mass to appear
above them on top of the cop car with a
giant battle axe he's like i've been
working on the railroad and it's like
smashes through this thing right trying
to take out callaway and this other guy
and that's when things get kind of nuts
because from there he basically ends up
jumping off the cop car
with once all these cops arrive on the
scene he just you know kind of wills
into existence
a flamethrower and like a machine gun
and just tor
just crushes everybody i mean literally
just like sprays down all these cops
with a flamethrower while he's shooting
the others with a machine gun i mean
it's just it's exceeded it's just
violence and chaos you never saw this in
the movie
there's absolute violence and chaos no
real rhyme or reason except to just
inflict as much
harm as humanly possible and so with
everything that's gone on the ultimate
idea behind the mask and ipkis is
we gotta skip town right like we gotta
get out of here like it wasn't really
our intention to start killing all these
cops you know but now that we have we're
gonna have too much heat coming down on
us right because we killed something
like two dozen cops the fbi like the
fed's coming in for sure right so like
let's just get the hell you know get
uh get the heck out of here so he throws
the mask on the bed he ends up grabbing
a
whole bunch of clothes right in some you
know a suitcase starts packing his stuff
up only to be shot from behind and where
his idea was to grab catherine
himself and to get out of town
catherine's like nope not gonna happen
and so in effect catherine's become the
next host for the mask right she's
essentially taking it for herself and
god only knows what's gonna happen with
her but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an
end if you are new here to comments
explain make sure you guys hit the sub
button to become part of the rob for if
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and i will catch you all
later
[Music]
peace
[Music]
do
[Music]
you